YURI GRINSHTEYN: In
our last episode,
we covered using distributed
tracing with OpenTelemetry
to identify the sources
of application latency.
But what do you do once
you know which microservice
is causing the issue?
Or what if your service is
serving an elevated error rate?
What do you do then?
This is where logging comes in.
Today, I'm going
to show you how you
can use Cloud Logging to ingest,
route, store, and view logs
from your services, and use
them to fully understand
what your service is doing.
Welcome to Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
But first, what do we
mean when we say logs?
We use logs to specifically
describe an event that
takes place in our system.
Logs are written by our
code, by the platform
our code is running on, and the
infrastructure we depend on.
Because logs and modern
systems are the descendants
of and sometimes still are
text log files written to disk,
a log entry analogous
to a line in log file
is the quantum unit of logging.
An entry will generally
consist of a timestamp that
indicates either when
the event took place
or when it was ingested
into the logging
system, and the payload,
either as unstructured
text data or structured
data, most commonly in JSON.
Logs can also carry
associated metadata,
like the resource that's
writing them, the log
name, and the severity
for each entry.
In Google Cloud, logs originate
from multiple sources.
First, Google Cloud
Services admit
logs for both auditing and
troubleshooting purposes.
These are enabled by default
and cannot be disabled directly.
The infrastructure provision
and apps you run on Google Cloud
can also emit logs.
These are largely controlled
by you, as the user.
Finally, networking components
and services emit logs as well.
Some of these,
like VPC flow logs,
can be controlled by the user,
while others are considered
part of the platform
and cannot be disabled.
No matter where
the logs come from,
Cloud Logging
receives log entries
through the Cloud Logging API.
From there, they pass
through the log router.
The sinks in the log
router check each log entry
against existing inclusion
and exclusion filters
that determine if
the log entry should
be sent to storage destinations,
including Cloud Logging
buckets, or excluded
entirely from ingestion.
You can use sinks to route
logs to multiple destinations,
such as Google Cloud
Storage for archiving,
BigQuery for
analytics, or Pub/Sub
to be processed further by
services such as Cloud Dataflow
or consumed by
third-party systems.
This is also where
exclusions happen,
if you have any configured.
Each sink lets you enter one or
more exclusion filters, which
let you exclude matching log
entries from being routed
to the sink's destination.
Typically, these are used as
a cost optimization approach.
Next, logs are sent
to log buckets,
which act as containers in
your Google Cloud projects
to store and organize
your logs data.
The logs that you
store in Cloud Logging
are indexed, optimized,
and delivered
to let you analyze
your logs in real-time.
Note that these are
different storage entities
than Cloud Storage buckets.
You can create sinks to
route all or just a subset
of your logs to any log bucket.
This flexibility allows you
to choose the Cloud project
in which your logs are stored
and what other logs are
stored with them.
Once your logs are
in buckets, you
can use log views to
control who has access
to the logs within
your log buckets.
You can centralize or
subdivide your log storage
based on your needs.
Custom log views provide
you with a granular way
to control access to the
logs in your buckets.
For example, consider
a scenario in which
you store all of
your organization's
logs in the central project.
Because log buckets can contain
logs from multiple projects,
you might want to control which
projects different users can
view logs from.
Using custom log views, you
can give one user access
to logs only from a single
project, and another user
access to logs from
all the projects.
So far, you've seen how platform
application and networking
logs are ingested through
the Cloud Logging API,
and how the logs router sends
them to their destinations,
either in log buckets
or logs sinks.
Next, let's have a look
at how you can view
and query logs in
Cloud Operations,
starting with the Logs Explorer.
To access the Logs Explorer,
go to the Products menu.
From Logging, select
Logs Explorer.
Initially, this shows you
all logs in your project.
On the left side, you can
use Log Fields to select just
the logs that you care about.
For example, if you have
a service running on GKE
and you want to figure out
what errors it's generating,
select Kubernetes
Container as the resource,
the name of your container,
and Error as the severity.
This will filter all the
logs down to just error logs
being produced by your service.
The histogram shows
you the volume
of logs that matches your
query over the selected time
interval.
If you want to zero in on
a specific point in time,
just drag the selectors
to the time you care about
and rerun the query.
Logs that match your
query are shown here,
in the Query Results section.
To get the full details
of a log entry, select it.
This will show you both the
metadata and the payload.
To see other logs that
have the same payload
or any other field, click
a field and selection
Show Matching Entries to
rerun the query for those.
The query is shown up here.
You can edit it
directly, and you
can save it to be used later.
Saved queries show up here.
Logs Explorer even generates
suggested queries for you
based on what's happening
in your project.
This is how you can use the Logs
Explorer to find the exact log
entries you need
to determine what's
happening with your service.
The Logs Explorer
is great at helping
you find the logs that you
need when you need them.
But what if you're
debugging a service
and want to watch the
logs in real-time?
This is where logs
streaming comes in.
Let's have a look.
In order to stream
logs, you first
have to find the logs
that you care about.
You can do that
by writing a query
or by using the log
field selectors.
So let's say you want to
troubleshoot a Cloud Composer
workflow.
Select Cloud
Composer Environment
on the left-hand side.
Once you've run the query, you
have the option to stream logs.
Click that button, and
the Query Results section
will expand to make it easier
to see and select log entries.
The logs are now streamed, with
the newest entries showing up
at the top of the list.
To pause the stream so that you
can inspect a particular entry,
just scroll down.
Then, select an
entry, just as before.
Once you're done
with that entry,
you can restart the
stream, and you'll
see the most recent logs at
the top of the list again.
If you have the information
you need, stop the stream,
and get back to the query.
So that's how you
can use log streaming
to see the log entries as
they appear, essentially
in real-time.
Streaming logs on the
console is fantastic,
but what if you prefer
to use the command line?
Well, there's now
a GCloud command
you can use to do just that.
Let's have a look at that.
To stream logs from
the command line,
simply use the gcloud
alpha logging tail command.
Use a filter to get just
the logs you care about.
You can use the Query Editor
to get the filter correct.
When you enter the command, the
tail session will be initiated,
and the logs will start
streaming into the console.
As you can see, this
can be hard to read.
So you may want to redirect
this to an output file
to make it easier.
That's how you can use the
command line to stream logs
by using the gcloud alpha
logging tail command.
Thanks for joining me today.
We covered the basics of Cloud
Logging, how logs are ingested,
routed, and stored, how you
can query your logs from log
buckets using Logs Explorer,
and how you can stream them
in real-time using the
console and the command line.
I hope this helps you find
issues faster and keep
your services reliable
and your users happy.
Thanks so much for watching.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]